I'm so over being slut-shamed Hannah
Browne faced off with her ex Luke P
during the bachelorettes men tell all
episode Monday night where Luke admitted
he has no regrets over the way he acted
throughout the season if I could go back
I wouldn't change a thing you know from
from day one coming here you know I felt
like I was on a rescue mission for him
first the episode kicked off with a
recap of Hannah and Lupe's heated fight
last week my husband would never say
what you said to me and honestly
as promised Luke returned to the rose
ceremony after his elimination tried to
win back the former pageant princess
which she was not having so I'm sorry if
I'm breaking your heart my heart isn't
broken yet because I'm still standing
here and this isn't over for me yet oh
my god whoa all right
[Applause]
he has a ring on his pocket right now he
was ready to propose to Hannah's
remaining men Tyler Jed Peter and even
host Chris Harrison helped her out
things were getting kind of tense did
you feel like a punch might have gotten
thrown in that moment I wasn't sure when
we were in Greece when when the other
guys walked up I thought maybe because I
know they had just had enough Luke
eventually left the show but took to
Instagram ahead of it all to share a
pointed message directed at ABC in his
lengthy post Luke defended returning to
the competition after his elimination
and claimed that Hannah openly declared
she wouldn't use the fantasy suites for
sex I'm not yes I can
when Hannah and Luke finally faced off
during the men tell all portion of the
show Luke endured a painfully awkward
hot seat session with Chris Harrison
where he got called out by several of
the men including at fan favorite Mike
Johnson your future wife is gonna be a
prisoner of you maybe you don't know how
to change Hanna addressed the topic of
sex with Luke live on the show Luke is
really obsessed with sex and it's baby
suits being about sex they said I'll
just tell everybody my sex life but
honestly did I sit around being like huh
Who am I gonna have sex with in the
fantasy suite
I didn't that wasn't something planned
that wasn't something that really was
everybody's business to know and it
wasn't your business to ever ask me I'm
so over being slut-shamed and being felt
like that makes me live my life and make
mistakes incent every single day and so
do you and so to use it you said you've
said use of you that's what grace is for
and I'm also not gonna say that me
having sex in a windmill was just like
The Scarlet Letter on my chest to have
like I'm not gonna stay in here and feel
that way and apologize to bachelor
nation for keeping him on their
television screens for so long it was
really frustrating for me during one of
the shows a commercial breaks we also
got to see a sneak peek of bachelor in
paradise which will feature the show's
first ever same-sex couple I know that I
love this girl
I'm just so happy that I found her
I can definitely picture being with her
for the rest of my life Demi tweeted
shortly after the clip aired quote I'm a
queer queen let's talk about paradise
because you're probably I would say you
and John Paul Jones probably the most
anticipated paradise attendees how did
things go for you paradise was amazing
it was so fun so emotional but
ultimately all worth it very very good
so much fun drama that you just get to
sit back and watch back to Hannah now
that Luke P is officially out of the
picture we can focus on part one of the
Bachelorette finale will she get engaged
you told me in our very first interview
that you didn't want to end up with a
lying sack of poo does that happen well
we don't know who I end up with yet and
we will have to continue to watch and
hopefully we'll find out more about
those pesky rumors surrounding Jed and
Peter's ex-girlfriend drama
Chris Harrison asurs fans they will get
answers what's the number one question
you want to ask Jen it's not I guess
it's not as much of a question I want
his perspective I want his say you know
there's there's always three sides to
the truth you know their version their
version and then the real version